الرئيس الاوكراني قد يكون ضيف اوروبا يوم
الخميس المقبل المناسبه انعقاد قمه رؤساء
دول وحكومات الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد تلقيه
دعوه من رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارل ميشيل
للمشاركه شخصيا في هذه القمه وفق ما اعلن
متحدث باسم المؤسسه الاوروبيه من دون ان
يدلي بتفاصيل اضافيه لاسباب امنيه اذ من
المقرر عقد قمه استثنائيه للقاده
الاوروبيين يومي الخميس والجمعه لبحث
تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا وتضامن الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع كييف ويتاكدت هذه الزياره
فانها ستكون الاولى
منذ بدايه الهجوم العسكري الروسي على
اوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
شباط من عام 2022 في السياق الدبلوماسيه
عقد مجلس الامن الدولي اجتماعا خصص للامن
والسلم في اوكرانيا استنكر فيه حلفاء كييف
الغربيون ما وصفوه باصرار روسيا على
الاستمرار في حربها ضد اوكرانيا
روسيا تريد اقلاعنا بانها تتعرض للظلم
متجاهله انها المعتديه لا يمكن ان نسمح
لروسيا بالاستمرار في استخدام الطاقه
والغذاء كسلاح يضر بنا جميعا ولكنه يقتل
الاوكرانيين
تتوقع المزيد من الدعم السياسي والعسكري
على بعد ايام من الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا